Great job on the quiz.
Now let's dive into numeric models
by introducing target variables.
Since the underlying math uses
variables and equations and we're
effectively solving an equation for
a variable that represents the outcome,
we'll be using target variable to
represent the outcome we're solving for.
All right, so
now that we know how to determine if
the target variable is numeric or
non-numeric we need to investigate
the target variable a little further.
This will help us identify
the most appropriate model.
But first,
let's focus on numeric variables.
At this point, we need to determine what
type of numeric variable the target is.
There are three types of numeric
variables, continuous, time based, and
count.
The first type of variable
we'll discuss is continuous.
A continuous variable is one that
can take on all values in a range.
For instance, your height can be
measured down to many decimal places.
We don't grow in even inch intervals.
The second type of numeric
variable is a time based variable.
The time based numeric variable is
one where you're trying to predict
what will happen over time.
This is often related to forecasting.
The third type of numeric
variable is a count variable.
Count variables are numbers that
are discrete positive integers.
They're called count numbers because
they're used to analyze variables that
you can count.
As modeling these types of variables
is not common in business,
we won't be covering this
topic in this course.
Now that we know the types
of numeric variables,
we can find the types of models that
are appropriate for the target variable.
If the target variable is
a continuous variable,
we can build continuous models
to solve the business problem.
If the target variable is time based,
we can do time-series analysis
to solve the business problem.
The important takeaway from this
lesson is the ability to determine
if you should use a numeric model, and
whether it should be a continuous or
a time based model.
I do want to take a moment to highlight
the fact that there are many more models
available to use, but
the focus of this course is on some
of the more commonly used models.
In subsequent courses,
we'll go into much more detail
about the specific models.